kanye west his wife kim is speaking out
about his bipolar disorder
while he is talking about ending their
marriage
kanye's new tweet started at 101
this morning i've been trying to get
divorced
they tried to fly in with two doctors to
5150 me
and then this one calling his
mother-in-law kris jenner
chris jong-un
every time i think that i've had a crazy
year i
live the next year it's even crazier
the since deleted tweet led to headlines
that kim also wants out of the marriage
but today a source tells e.t kim is not
planning to divorce kanye right now
the couple have a prenup and all their
money has been
figured out at the start of their
relationship if kim wanted to divorce
him she'd just
file but she's not planning to at this
time when he gets ramped up
he can't control what he says he's like
yeah i say crazy
but i've always said great but that's
why i'm
kanye kim herself spoke out on instagram
posting
he is a brilliant but complicated person
who has to deal with the pressure and
isolation
that is heightened by his bipolar
disorder those who are close with kanye
know his heart and understand his words
sometimes do not align with his
intentions
kanye was really cute he's like so this
is what for better for worse means
amidst all this kim is staying strong
for their children
we're told she wants to help kanye but
he only
seems to get more upset when she or
anyone tries to help
i think it's difficult sometimes to have
that conversation when somebody is
mid-episode but i think the most
important thing
is to calmly and objectively talk about
the observations that you see without
judging them right so
instead of putting negative descriptors
just talk to them about
what you're seeing how is everything
going are you feeling okay
you